Это часть 9, с экраном.
Давайте создать еще один митинг.
Я создал еще один митинг.
Делать еще один митинг.
Давайте только в английском.
Да.
Дисабл транслал.
Оскар, вы не заблете ли это на вашем сайте?
Субтитры делал DimaTorzok
Брайзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейзер, пейз
Мы попробуем это по телефону, но нет, не сегодня.
Я не вижу никакие кнопки для этого, я не вижу ни кнопки, я не вижу ни кнопки, я не вижу ни кнопки.
Но когда я открываю эту письмо, я не вижу ни кнопки.
О, я тоже вижу это.
So, we can paint on a page, me and Oskar, Oskar just painted a smile, so we can paint on the screen with dots, like, that works, so laser walks, next, next, recording, I'll stop sharing screen, this is part 10 recording,
Чтобы record, I need to open the button More and start server recording.
So now I see the top bottom that recording started.
The only thing I see is that we disabled our translation,
but I still see under the Oscars that there is button transcribing.
Maybe because our language is still different for our accounts,
но мы получили много флешек, но мы получили много флешек.
Теперь я запрещу свою флешку.
Я открыл эту флешку в интермайон, но я не вижу никаких флешек для этого.
Я не вижу никаких историй для этого.
Maybe I can check my email.
Yeah, I have a lot of messages with the meeting summary.
Oscar, can you please check your email too?
I think you have any summaries.
I opened a few links with the meeting summary and they are empty.
I see only meeting summary, date and that's all.
Meeting or when you open a meeting summary.
Alright, alright.
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
Let's try it, let's try it.
Find any recorded.
So, what we see is that when I stopped recording, the record started downloaded on Oscar page.
Am I right, Oscar?
When I created recording, I stopped it, nothing happened on my site.
Okay, let me check with these parts.
Can you do the test on your site?
Can you open this, your recording?
Describe what you are seeing there.
It works fine, the record is right.
Скажите, это 14 секунд?
Это будет долго, да?
Нужно проверить...
Я не вижу...
Я не могу найти ничего не записывания
на мою сайт, на мой аккаунт
Может, Оскар,
ты можешь найти...
Может, вы оставили
записывания
на whole page?
Я не знаю...
Дай мне секунду,
мне нужно перейти на мой ear
Я могу остановиться сейчас.